let's at least agree to stop babies that
could feel pain being ripped apart into
a okay right good go now when people say
oh you're time for the Green Deal the
green gnudi I didn't have time to read
through all of it before today's show
it does seem pretty insane and it does
leave me to the point that I do want to
discuss tonight why I believe that
President Trump is going to be
re-elected and the main reason for this
is that Democrats keep giving him gifts
they wondered like how he won in the
first place hear that like how did dogs
from how could he have possibly won and
how could he possibly win again I'll
tell you exactly how the left continues
to give this man gifts he really is
there's like a Chauncey Gardiner effect
he's not necessarily doing everything
right they're just doing everything
wrong it looks brilliant by comparison
so I think do think at the State of the
Union which occurred this week showcase
exactly what I'm talking with just how
far left the DNC has gone but something
that's important note seventy / 70 is at
76 76 76 percent of Americans approved
of the speech what's really bad for
Democrats is that 81 percent of
independents approved jobs range I think
we've all relation is from from from
YouGov and the more that the left
continues to push through their agenda
toward the left the Democrats I should
say pushing their agenda toward left the
more likely to these independent voters
who everyone's a trump it just has this
ceiling right he has this ceiling and
it's his base well the truth is his base
actually those people are the biggest
problems with the president Trump will
get into those in a second it seemed
that the independence actually the
people in the middle are really starting
to thaw on the guy and he had 81 percent
of them to support the reality show got
yeah like think about this for a second
how badly must you screw up that the guy
who is literally trademark you're fired
yes beating the crap out of you let's go
through kind of four examples I think
this is one that's really important
easily late-term abortion so here's a
clip where President Trump called for
legislation to end the late term
abortions and he mentions Northam
discussion of killing babies after birth
this is an important clip for people to
see there you go now to defend the
dignity of every person I am asking
Congress to pass legislation to prohibit
the late term abortion of children who
can feel pain
there are people who refuse to stand at
that think about this for say you're an
independent or washing let's at least
agree to stop babies that could feel
pain being ripped apart into okay right
good enough no you're gonna sit on your
hands for that do you have any idea how
the optics looking here's something
that's really important I think maybe
you guys aren't necessarily cuz you
weren't really like political junkies in
the last election and I know you'll vote
in the next election but Trump by the
way was pro-choice yeah up until he ran
as a Republican effectively and
conservatives were really really leery
of it because of that right yeah we
never he was conservative they didn't
think he was conservative and so Donald
Trump found himself in a pickle in the
primaries particularly because he had to
appeal to his base of conservatives he
had to prove to them that he was pro-gun
that he was pro-life while still
appeasing moderates and that's hard to
do when they think that you can't went
over either of them now again the
Democrats have given him a gift and that
he can do you can now appeal to his
pro-life base and even the moderates who
just don't want to see babies being born
alive killed all he has to say is hey
hey a forty week old baby big chapter
the headband dance that's required think
about that for a second yeah all the
Democrats had to do was say hey most
Americans are relatively pro-choice
because it's a term that we created to
trick them and some of them are stupid
so let's go with that and instead they
said forty week abortions right forty
weeks and Donald Trump was I'd call your
bluff where the left is lost all around
is a pushing for for open borders so in
the State of the Union Trump mentioned
ice rescuing women and children from sex
traffickers watch what I think Acacio
Nina Pinta Santa Maria corner of tez
refuses to clap for for this here's the
clip more than 1500 sadistic traffickers
have been put behind bars
[Applause]
on the road the left
stone cold [ __ ]
should I
I'll get out
I'll get up first slavery I don't like
him and I'll go that like this you just
handed him a gift by the way they were
wearing white if you're wearing white
for women's rights gosh you've got des
who are you wearing I'm wearing white
for women's rights except all the
underage hookers against their will and
here's the thing not even talking about
the sex trafficking okay that's one that
again if you just want you have to play
the game in politics everyone knows this
a little bit we don't like it but when
someone says ending sex trafficking even
if you go home second I know that Cortes
when she's talking about and in sex
trafficking it's actually attached to
the green new deal pill and that's
actually about seventy percent tax so I
don't like it but she did say in sex
trafficking all right later they didn't
clap at that but if you go even further
in the issue a new CBS poll shows that
72% of Americans agreed with Trump
specifically on immigration anyway
saying it it's just in from our CBS news
instant poll here following the
president's State of the Union 76
percent of speech watchers said they
approved of what they heard I'm very
surprised a large percentage err I'm
very surprised that any of these
percentages are true that's why I had to
play that clip though you would believe
that I'm not just saying it here's a let
me just paint a picture to prove it just
a moment here okay I'm trying to
actually wrap my head round to do a fat
check Donald Trump there he said we we
had burgers stacked a mile high at the
White House they're like actually they
were placed in more of a horizontal
spread really one couldn't account for
the vertical metrics because of the
buttons and depending on the temperature
of the room about this for a second okay
the guy who said you could do whatever
you like you dragged by the and
disgusted a whole nation now has the
moral high ground because you've decided
to vilify him because he's against sex
trafficking and he had the number off by
two percent yes you couldn't possibly
make it easier for
now everyone forgets about the grab bag
that you go actually that 33% of people
who are raped when they try to get here
against their will
it's 31% you better get in line
president but I'll need to see your that
PC and they're like you know what I kind
of am yeah I should almost be
prioritizing the women who are being
raped here's the second example for
against the prime example the left of
course is pushing socialism this is
another reason I think President Trump
is going to - when they're out right
pushing everybody's do you veiled yeah
releases like when people said we think
that Barack Obama is kind of a socialist
right yeah socialism is actually it's a
dog whistle which it's the in word think
he's a socialist by the way people in
there people like in Norway who are
socialist - they're not black at all
actually like really white it's really
strong for some reason we have no idea
as to why yet we're still running some
genetic testing but we actually think
that Barack Obama is like a Norwegian
socialist that's it Trump just said that
we're never going to be a socialist
country and look at who refuses to
applaud here you go
socialism in our country America was
founded on liberty and independence and
not government coercion domination and
control we are born free we were
[Applause]
[Laughter]
planned poorly my afternoon nap zoom in
close-ups in the history of presidential
speeches had sex with a crazier older
grumpy cat Bernie Sanders and a Cassio's
Nina Pinta Santa Maria Cortez these are
the starters their actual social she
actually thinks that she's going to pass
some kind of 70% tax I explained it
somehow
the notion of socialism to that
particular regime are you what do you
think about the president why he did
that well I think I think that he needs
to do it because he feels like he feels
himself losing on the issues in public
has been overwhelmingly popular even
some with a majority of Republican
voters supporting supporting of what
we're talking about when we talked about
a 70 percent marginal tax rate on
incomes over ten million dollars 60% of
Americans approve it a majority of
Republicans support socialism but I
thought this was well known heyyou
person next to me is this well it's not
well known I don't know what I'm saying
she probably with the wasps or something
let's be honest here oh my gosh do we
have back what that sounds like an
intelligent woman know what the pretend
so you just think Nancy Pelosi doesn't
sound like an idiot i I think she's
wrong I think she's the only person in
politics who's proactively evil but she
just sounded like an idiot
doesn't sound like an idiot no this girl
sounds like a moral great you think the
government is that giving you free stuff
people still don't want how to attack
some so with the prank calls this week
where we call black businesses yeah
would it make you more or less likely
support governor are familiar with
supports increased taxes hmm
the opposite of that I think the
greatest example of course of the gifts
that the left has been they've been
giving Donald Trump and I hope they do
it again in 2020 is um they went Hillary
Clinton in a general election yeah
likely the one person Donald Trump was
capable of eating at that time truck
pulled very badly for people who forgot
this leading up to the election almost
every single pollster got it wrong
because he was pulling so badly and he's
been receiving nothing but hostile media
coverage since here's the thing the
choice in 2020 is very different from
2016 you are not a trump guy and I was
not a Trump guy in the primaries now we
argued about it we argued about it
because I member saying well listen if
he does win you know he's gonna be the
guy at that point but it was my guy like
Carly Fiorina I like Ted Cruz so the
choice though in 2020 s4w in 2016 2016 a
lot of people thought that both Hillary
and Trump were kind of taking us toward
a cliff I think ben shapiro summarized
it as though the concerns of many by the
way he said the fear was that if Trump
got in the office and he did a bad job
it'd be like we're heading toward the
cliff just as we'd be heading toward the
cliff with Hillary Clinton but with
Donald Trump there would be no break
right because no Republican would be
elected after Donald Trump if he did as
bad of a job that many people
anticipated myself included in the
primaries I remember saying like I do I
think we deserve to lose if we run him
in the primary yeah of course when he
was against Hillary Clinton I mean
listen come on you just take the free
shots when you're giving them people
thought Hillary Clinton that was
ultimately a politician right that's
what people didn't like her they thought
she's a politician but has left us go
relatively moderate you know the thing
with Hillary cleanness I did she wasn't
super fun she wasn't there was Bernie
Sanders and Hillary Clinton yeah Trump
on the other hand people also thought a
lot of people think because he says bad
words that he's somehow extreme he was
actually seen as really pretty moderate
and not that conservative so a lot of
conservatives weren't big fans of Trump
as a matter of fact I think you'll be
surprised when you look at those voting
blocs evangelicals voted for Trump
because they had to but not all of them
probably likely fewer in a lot of
municipalities but you saw a lot of
Union voters would have didn't go on
Democrat the Blue Dogs go for Donald
Trump so a lot of those people held
their noses though the Evangel the
Christians the true conservatives and
voted for Trump because Hillary Clinton
was such an insufferable that's really
why but now in 2020 were choosing
between Donald Trump who's been really
pretty conservative if you look
was a president outside of the trade
issue and pretty good and all Democrats
who swung so far the left their right
nut hasn't seen them in a month we know
they want abortion up to 40 weeks
70% tax rates as you just saw completely
socialized health care they want to
destroy our economy on principle versus
Donald Trump who has done well by nearly
all metrics available to us at this
point besides tweeting mean words some
of which are misspelled let's be honest
outside of that he's done pretty well
the choice in 2020 when they say it's
stark sir well we think there's a stark
contrast to the Democrats and Donald
Trump it is but in a positive way for
Trump because these gifts that the
Democrats keep giving them so when
Republicans say that we need to be more
moderates this is so many people feel
like hey listen we need a more moderate
Republican party to come to the middle I
go hon a second look how far the left is
going don't stare a gift horse in the
mouth okay if you liked this video you
know you watch videos on YouTube a fiber
Jimmy Kimmel if I were Stephen Colbert
or Trevor Noah I would tell you to
subscribe but I have no corporate
overlords who demand that I do this
demeaning promo I do the demeaning promo
because I choose to subscribe or hit the
notification bell because I need you I
need you please do it